Speaker 1: The other aspect related to
white Christian nationalism in this country
is Tucker Carlson, who hosts a weekly
racist fireside chat on Fox News,
the highest rated program in the history
of the network hosted by Tucker Carlson,
who has said that immigrants didn't delineate
between illegal immigrants or legal immigrants. He
just said immigrants make our country poorer and
dirtier. He said it. He has said white supremacy
is a myth. It doesn't exist. He's now shifted
that really the only racism is anti-white racism.
And he went on this JAG last night
about the new crisis in America.
They're going to they're going to gin
this up. This new crisis is white racism.
To his aging out audience filled
with lolling to sleep octogenarians,
convincing an elder population that there
was a new crisis in America. Watch this.
Speaker 3: So clearly the Democratic Party needs
a new emergency, at least until we start sending
ground troops to Ukraine and the population
becomes suitably hysterical again. So because
they need an emergency, they found one. And the
new emergency turns out to be the old emergency,
which is white racism. Now, unfortunately for the
Democratic Party, white racism is one commodity
like cedar boards that's getting harder to
find. Very few unarmed black men are killed by
white cops these days. Where's George Floyd when
you need them? So instead, in a pinch, they've
settled for an unarmed black man killed by black
cops, which they've informed us over the last,
despite all appearances, is still the product of
white racism. And Barack Obama enthusiastically
agrees. This is Barack Obama's lane. He was
elected president twice on this kind of stuff,
so he immediately jumped into the middle
of the Memphis tragedy to remind us
that white middle class Republicans did.
Speaker 1: This Blood is on their hands.
Speaker 3: Selma, Dr. King, Rodney King, Trayvon
Martin, they're all the fruit of white supremacy.
Speaker 1: How are they not the
fruit of white supremacy? Tucker.
How is it the disproportionate killing of Oman
black men in this country is not a byproduct
of white supremacy and systemic racism in our
country. You vile, putrid white supremacist.
Who still is propped up by advertisers on Fox
News. Where's George Floyd when you need him?
He declares. This is wretched, reprehensible
behavior. A disgusting display.
Sponsored by whomever. By the Mypillow guy, I
guess. And then this crack about until we send
ground troops to Ukraine as though this is our
war, as though we've been invaded by Russia or
as though we've invaded Ukraine. It's all a play
to create a frenzy and a panic in his audience
as he declares the new crisis to be white
racism. He's actually creating the new crisis.
On his program. Listen, I've talked a lot about
Tucker Carlson, the googly eyed feather duster,
the haircut, the soft skinned, smooth brained
moron. And if it weren't for the fact that he
has the most ratings, the greatest, most popular
show in the history of Fox News and Fox News far
and away gets better ratings than any other
cable news network. If it weren't for that,
the fact that people listen to him, people trust
him. People take his conspiracy theories as fact.
They take him at his word that he's correct.
You can you can throw a suit or a bow tie on
a racist. They're still a racist Just because he
doesn't have a skinhead and Nazi tattoos doesn't
make him a new Nazi. It's exactly what he is.
And he thrives on it. He profits off of it.
And he has the ear of the only declared candidate
for president in the Republican Party, Donald
Trump. He has regular text conversations with Alex
Jones, and he's now patterning his show almost in,
I mean, sans selling vitamins and
supplements. It's the same thing.
This is dangerous. And we need to still
be aware of it. We need to still keep on
top of this and keep it in the forefront
of our minds and not just let it go away
as well. He's just loopy and conspiracy
theory. He has an audience. He rallies
support. People quote him. People cite him in
their manifestos after they commit violence.
We need to stay on top of this. Once again, I
am Jessy Dallimore. You can find me online. I
am perpetually on the internet. You can subscribe
to my YouTube show Dallimore daily. Just search my
name. Follow me on social media. I am on Twitter,
Instagram and TikTok at dallimore and I'd love
for you to subscribe to my twice weekly podcast
called I doubt It wherever you find podcasts.